I think there's one place to look and
it's not because I'm interested in them
I think in this global world what we've
minimized in this idea that the world is
becoming global we're all becoming the
same that the world is flat we've
minimized the role of cities and this is
why I'm been spending a lot of my time
working on cities not just because i
love cities but because i think they're
important I actually think they're the
key institutional actors you know in
rise of the creative class I said a
couple things I said one that place is
coming to replace the company as the key
social and organizing unit of the
creative economy its place that brings
together people its place that collects
people talented people ambitious people
whatever entrepreneurial people its
place that attaches us to work in a
mobile society and I said also that the
key struggles of our time would no
longer be factory struggles they would
literally be struggles about how our
cities are used who's moved around
gentrification all of those things are
coming true but what I think is really
interesting is that if you look at
mayor's around the world you know and
the question ioss is why would somebody
like in your hometown somebody like Mike
Bloomberg did you remember the mayor's
the people who used to be mayor of New
York right I'm for North where I grew up
Corey buckler's the mayor of newark now
these were like completely dysfunctional
people who were mayor's so you've got a
whole new group of people who are more
business sophisticated and in some ways
let's not even take the united states
who do you think's more powerful the
Prime Minister of England or the Mayor
of London i'm making a broad statement
they may be both very powerful people in
China who is really powerful the guy who
runs China or the mayor of Shanghai so
the mayor's have their hands on this
really interesting very powerful
economic unit and I think at the city
level we're beginning to see people ask
these kinds of deep questions what I
worry about is almost a disconnect and
the other thing that's so fascinating I
can tell you you could tell me anyone
out there could say the difference
between a democrat or republican a
liberal and conservative in a congress
or in a parliament at the national level
they're like ideologically distinct
people I go to visit the city I need a
mayor Democrat Republican liberal
conservative if I don't know I can't
tell
you know what is Bloomberg what does
cory booker what is you know my friend
John Hickenlooper in Denver I don't know
I mean I guess I could go find out but
they all seem very sad really funny in
Washington DC they're all very similar
and it's not ideologically driven it's
about making the city work pragmatically
so i think the real place to look for
these best practices is at the city
level and you know this the cities are
probably the place is doing the most for
the environment and we know that they're
environmentally dense cities are
environmentally better anyway they're
making because they have two big
advances in education in retooling your
school systems they're the right place
to do productivity policy or economic
policy not at the federal level because
they're closer to the action so I think
the place to look is at the city level
and I think maybe maybe as much as we
need G to write the China in the US and
Lee needed g8 we needed g20 maybe what
we really need is to get some of these
mayor's involved in the dialogue and
begin to learn not from everything
they've done but but some of the best
examples and I think the federal
government's the national governments
would be well served by saying look
we've got companies out there we can tap
we've got workers in union organizations
we can have for information but these
mayors and these cities are actually
developing in a very small way in a
local way programs and approaches that
we should take a look at
friends in the state's I come look at
Toronto I mean we're we're hanging
that's why so glad you could come up
here I mean I think in Toronto the whole
effort won the stim entrepreneurship to
to really invest in the creative economy
and that is creating a backlash here
we're getting artists and musicians
saying hold on come on well I'm not a
commodity I'm an artist I don't know if
I want it and this dialogue that's
happening in this city where we begin to
see real estate price appreciation
because we have it here again and people
say no no wait we have to go slow trying
to figure out this balance between
entrepreneurial action the nature of the
development in the city the engagement
of creative industries and creative
people and find a balance we're really
concerned in Toronto about mounting
inequality now that we don't have any
quality like we have in the United
States but my God we're beginning to see
economic segmentation people are very
concerned about this the thing about
Toronto that really blows my mind we are
having another mayor's race our current
mayor is a terrific mayor and he's the
spectacular guy and cares about this and
understands it we have two or three
candidates already with their hats in
the ring all of whom would be
spectacular mayors I mean it's like
there's three four people running for
mayor all who are equally smart and
engaged I but I think focusing on
entrepreneurship is one focusing on of
course on technology and that's been a
big theme you know Mike Porter and
cluster building that's been a big theme
of urban economic development now for a
generation I think this idea of getting
creative people engaged that we started
to kick off my team and I getting
creative people engaged getting them
motivated getting them involved in the
economy a dealing with urban inequality
dealing with the environment making a
city that's creative sustainable
inclusive and just I mean would be that
is a not just a city that's rich and one
of the things that we've been trying to
do is figure out other measures of
economic activity that are not just
material goods so you know everybody out
there has heard about happiness we've
actually been measuring the happiness
not just of Nations but if cities and
states cities and states that have a
bigger creative economy the people are
happier the role of diversity I think
this is a key 1 i've talked about this
till I'm blue in the face you can't have
a great city unless you're open to
diversity
everyone can contribute we find that the
other thing that we've been looking at
which is just a mind-blower I started to
get interested in health and I think
part of it is I saw I saw people my
parents were lifelong smokers my dad
died of lung cancer I hate those things
I'm sorry I saw people stopped smoking
I've never been a smoker but and I saw
all these people starting to lose weight
right it became a big thing or going to
lose weight they're going to get in
shape so I advanced this little
hypothesis what if the shift to smoking
and and away from obesity what if this
was something that was being caused by
the post industrial economy itself not
just rising incomes what if we could try
to determine that healthier behavior
whether it's higher levels of
satisfaction in your life and with
everything but more no more smoking and
no more eating you know massive
quantities of fast food we've just been
doing this research but the results are
so mind-blowing in places that have more
of this creative economy that have nutri
did it and built it that it's more
robust have higher educated populations
more involvement in the creative
industries significantly lower rates of
obesity significantly lower rates of
smoking controlling for income and
economics so I think something is
happening in the places that do this to
go quite beyond and and the mayor's are
beginning we're beginning to get a
handle you might say no smoking policy
or the labeling of food all of these
little things you know a good buddy of
mine came back from England he's a great
economic developer he actually runs the
big economic development organization
for for North America tax with the world
but its main lead us in Canada and he
said you know in our field economic
development in city development used to
have a big Fisher or a big game hunter
go out and get that big auto plan to
that big convention center and that
bring that big small team to town he
said if you want to do that go to China
I mean it was most remarkable things
that all the big projects the big plans
the big steel mills there were going to
be tried if you want to do that go to
China he said what's so interesting
about managing a city now is it a bunch
of little things that we typically
haven't thought about making your
creative industries better making sure
your artists and musicians have support
making sure the place is beautiful and
physically interesting to people
investing in parks and green space
making sure that entrepreneurs right
like Bloomberg's do we have the supports
they need into space the affordable
space Jane Jacobs said new ideas require
old building
all of these millions and zillions of
little things that are very locally
rooted that upgrade the capability of
people and that's a mind shift that's
beginning to happen in some cities